[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos a la entrevista de
France 24 nuestro invitado de hoy es
mijael kowski es un antiguo
Magnate ruso del petróleo fue
encarcelado durante 10 años por Vladimir
Putin vive exiliado en Londres donde
dirige la ong Open rusha Señor gracias
por estar con nosotros yo se lo
agradezco
señor
hace un año que comenzó la guerra en
Ucrania Cómo ve las cosas
cree que una guerra contra la otan y
Rusia es inevitable algunos incluso
hablan de la tercera guerra mundial
no pretendía un enfrentamiento directo
con la otan
pero ahora todo el mundo en Rusia está
convencido de que no estamos en guerra
con Ucrania sino con la otan y por ello
si Putin tiene éxito en su jugada en
Ucrania no hay duda de que cruzar las
fronteras de los países de la otan no
será un obstáculo para él
así que para usted si Putin logra su
objetivo en Ucrania serán los países
bálticos Polonia por ejemplo
estoy absolutamente convencido de que
Putin no puede parar
en un año de guerra ha creado una fuerza
muy grande e influyente de Patriotas
nacionales
y Putin detiene la guerra por un lado
no podrá mejorar la situación de su
población
porque la tierra ocupada Es una carga
muy grande
y por otro estar abajo la presión de Los
Patriotas nacionales que son de hecho su
base política
en esta situación
ya ha conseguido cuatro veces resolver
sus problemas electorales
con una nueva guerra
no hay motivos para dudar
declara lo mismo una quinta vez
los ucranianos por su parte pretenden
ganar la guerra en 2023 y reconquistar
todos sus territorios incluida crimea
si esto ocurre será el fin de Vladimir
Putin
si los países occidentales cambian su
actitud en respecto al apoyo tan
comedido que han adoptado para Ucrania
entonces Ucrania podrá aplastar a Putin
con eficacia
y un Putin Derrotado perderá con toda
probabilidad su poder
entonces cree que Ucrania con el apoyo
de occidente puede ganar la guerra o
cree que será muy difícil porque Putin
sabe que su supervivencia está
probablemente en juego en esta guerra
en cualquier caso va a ser muy duro y
esto por tres condiciones indispensables
la primera condición es la resistencia
de los ucranianos su capacidad de
recuperación
en segundo lugar está la capacidad de
los europeos y los estadounidenses para
suministrar armas a Ucrania en las
cantidades necesarias
En tercer lugar si la sociedad rusa está
convencida de que esta guerra es la
guerra de Putin y no la guerra de Rusia
la oposición rusa está trabajando en el
tercer aspecto que he mencionado
así pues en sus escritos en sus
declaraciones usted considera que las
posibilidades de que se produzca una
Revolución interna que Roque a putinson
extremadamente bajas Entonces por qué
esto no significa que una gran mayoría
de rusos apoya a su presidente
la sociedad rusa está profundamente
minada por la propaganda
pero este apoyo a la guerra no debe
sobrevalorarse
hay un 30% de la sociedad rusa que está
realmente a favor de esta guerra
[Música]
y hay un 50% de la gente que no quiere
discutir las órdenes
pero si Putin va hacia una derrota
militar todo el mundo Se volverá contra
él y él lo sabe
usted también dice que lo más difícil
para Rusia no es tanto deshacerse de
Vladimir Putin sino del putinismo
cree que si Vladimir Putin quizás por un
fracaso en Ucrania dejara el poder
no significa que alguien mejor vendría
en su lugar es este el verdadero reto
para ustedes los opositores
mi experiencia vital me ha bastado para
ver que el absolutamente democrático
Chelsea
una vez que tuvo plenos poderes
se convirtió en un autócrata autoritario
y yo no creo en eso
creo que Rusia necesita una división de
poderes necesita federalización
parlamentarismo y la autoridad de las
autoridades locales
es una opinión que aún no comparte toda
la oposición
algunos aún creen en el ser bueno
puede que sus intenciones sean buenas
tal vez les gustaría ver a su
representante en el lugar de Putin Y eso
es contra lo que estoy luchando
y aquí me gustaría convencer a occidente
de que cualquiera por muy buena persona
que ocupe el lugar del zar en Rusia
a necesitar encontrar un enemigo
exterior para conservar el poder
está ha sido siempre la regla Y esta es
la única explicación que fue posible
para todos los Ares de Rusia para
mantenerse en el poder y esto debe ser
detenido
una persona a la que se habla mucho como
tal vez alguien a quien le gustaría
hacer el zar en lugar de Vladimir Putin
es el jefe del grupo de seguridad
privada Wagner y fenigosing
se ha convertido en un actor de la
guerra en Ucrania pero algunos se
preguntan si tiene una ambición política
mayor
podría ser un sucesor de Putin o está a
las órdenes del mismo Vladimir Putin
de momento pregosin está a las órdenes
de Putin
Pero puede llegar un momento en que
quiera poner a uno de los suyos en este
puesto
no creo que él mismo quiera el puesto
el peligro de ver a Putin sustituido por
un hombre tan autoritario como él es un
peligro real
y es este peligro el que hay que
combatir
creo que podremos superar este peligro
porque el sistema de equilibrio que
construyó Putin en su entorno es
extremadamente difícil de reconstituir
Así que tras su marcha habrá conflictos
Dentro de este séquito
última pregunta vivió 10 años en prisión
en condiciones a veces muy difíciles en
particular usted se refirió al
confinamiento Solitario como isito una
ruta directa al cementerio alexey
navalni está actualmente en prisión 11
años y medio en una colonia
penitenciaria de máxima seguridad tiene
la impresión de que Vladimir Putin
quiere mantenerlo allí o en su opinión
es plausible un escenario como el suyo
en el que usted acabó siendo liberado
para sorpresa de todos
por desgracia creo que el Putin de hoy
no es el Putin de 2013
si salgo de la cárcel Putin considera
que fue un grave error haberlo aceptado
y es un error que no volverá a cometer
con naval ni
pero navalni saldrá de la cárcel
otros como Vladimir karamuza y liaching
y andrey y muchos otros saldrán de
prisión
debo pasta saldrán de la cárcel porque
Putin perderá esta guerra se verá
obligado a dejar su puesto
estará en el banquillo de los acusados o
en el cementerio y todos los presos
políticos serán liberados
mijael jodercowski Muchas gracias por
responder a las preguntas de France 24 y
gracias a ustedes por seguir esta
entrevista en nuestros canales
[Música]